I'd like to show you an abys locked
within its depths are bewildering and
uncanny Abominations the keepers of this
Abyss believe they are in control they
are wrong this Abyss is the universe of
SCP which began as a seemingly
straightforward website where community
members create and classify abomination
yet from this site the franchise has
grown so vast influenced so many people
that trying to Fathom its totality feels
like gazing into an unending expanse so
for this entry into the archive I'll
explore not just the universe itself but
how SCP became one of the most
gargantuan and uncontainable forces on
the internet and to do that I have to
start at the
beginning on June June 22nd 2007 an
anonymous user made a post describing in
dry academic language a concrete
sculpture that moves when left
unobserved snapping the necks of anyone
who breaks eye contact with it the
sparse description was accompanied by an
image labeled SCP
173 at the time meaningless letters and
numbers nobody could have predicted that
this was the birth of something
astonishing Flash Forward several months
and numerous people were creating their
own anomalies with the same label format
most were rather simple with SCP 628 for
example essentially being a reptile
that's virtually Invincible but the
universe was starting to take shape with
the SCP Foundation determined to be a
secret organization responsible for
containing and studying mysterious
phenomena and with this framework things
exploded on the current website there
are more than 7,000 unique entries many
of which are exceedingly original the
entry for SCP 2521 for example contains
no text whatsoever composed instead of
strange infographics that are confusing
at first Until you realize they're
telling you about a monster that will
appear if it's written or spoken about
it's some genuinely creative horror but
no two entries are the same
scp-106 or the old man is an unfriendly
looking fellow who can corrode any Sur
Surf and hunts humans classic effective
horror SCP 294 is a coffee machine that
can dispense anything including abstract
Concepts like musical Talent OR lethal
nuclear waste which is definitely a new
one certain posts have achieved unique
popularity like 049 aka the plague
doctor who looks like a human in a 15th
century plague outfit until you look at
an x-ray which reveals the mask is part
of his body this entity claims to have a
cure to any disease which spoiler alert
is just death not every SCP will connect
with every person but there are so many
entries with such distinct styles that
it's practically a certainty that at
least one post will draw you in and once
you're in there's no getting out because
the posts themselves are just the tip of
the iceberg many of the best entries on
the site are text only which has
inspired a legion of talented artists to
create their own renderings of what
different scps might look like that
original SCP 173 for example no longer
has an image associated with it because
the initial photo was actually an
unlicensed picture of the sculpture
Untitled 2004 by Japanese artist isumi
Cato but don't worry because there are
thousands of images reinterpreting the
evil statue some of which are really
creative like this one from Valdes Evia
an artist I've covered before on the
channel but it's not just famous scps
that get this treatment there are
absolutely stunning works of art for the
most obscure entries and I think the
reason has to do with the format of scps
themselves when you read an entry that
speaks to you it's hard not to obsess
over what the anomaly might look like
and since many posts have no art of
their own that Obsession often explodes
out into artistic
Recreations but when you read an entry
like SCP 10 or the flesh that hates
about a virus that turns humans and
animals into Blobby tendrils of meat you
don't just want still images you want to
see it move and you can there are
literally tens of thousands of
animations and liveaction short films up
on YouTube that bring scps to life in
three glorious horrifying Dimensions the
channel forlorn Foundry is home to some
of my favorites creating fancy CGI
Recreations of various anomalies but
complex visual effects aren't the only
way to effectively bring an SCP to life
some of the most chilling forlorn
Foundry adaptations are the simplest
ones like their unbearably
claustrophobic exploration of scp1 1562
an infinite tunnel slide that is
impossible to escape from once you get
stuck within its chimal depths or the
similar SCP 087 a pitch black staircase
you can never reach the bottom of my
favorite moment in this video is when
someone trapped on the stairs drops a
coin off the railing and the anticipated
sound of the coin hitting the ground
just never comes it's seriously clever
film making conveying the dread and
anxiety of the original entry and I
think that's part of what motivates
forlorn Foundry and similar channels a
desire to recreate how the best scps
feel when you read them and I'm guessing
ing that's why there are so many
adaptations of SCP
3008 Ikea a place where children could
play while their parents shopped or
friends could share good cheer his
vision has come to pass Ikea has just
opened its 70th
star the most renowned SCP in the
subcategory of immeasurable spaces is
the infinite Ikea an extradimensional
version of the already labyrinthine
retail store that literally never ends
something about wandering the furniture
displays in perpetuity forever unable to
find your way back to the entrance has
struck a cord with the internet leading
to countless digital Recreations I've
seen references to the infinite Ikea
well beyond the sphere of SCP there are
entire fan games about this concept
letting you get lost among the endless
Furniture displays as a gnawing
loneliness sets in it's a sensation that
that I find strangely familiar I'm sure
many of us have early memories of
getting separated from our parents in
the supermarket even if it was just for
a brief moment the aisles suddenly felt
larger and more threatening and there
was a sense that you'd never find a way
out I think many of the most well-known
scps are rooted in these half-remembered
childhood fears which helps explain
their infectious popularity there's
something Universal about the vertigo of
of a really big staircase or again an
empty store that allows scps to leave a
wide audience feeling unsettled but
they're also kind of hilarious like
being stuck forever in an Ikea is
disturbing yet at the same time really
funny in a way that's difficult to
quantify when nightfalls in the store
faceless monsters wearing Ikea employee
uniforms start hunting you through the
dark and while logically that should
make things scarier to to me it only
adds to the humor this paradoxical
undercurrent of Comedy is present in a
lot of scps scp1 1609 was a chair that
helpfully teleported to people when they
needed to sit down until someone put it
through a wood chipper turning it into a
rageful pile of mulch that teleports
into people's lungs and while murderous
sawdust would be terrifying it's pretty
hysterical in the abstract and this I
believe is the other massive component
to scp's unparalleled expansion even if
every entry won't scare you chances are
at least a few will make you laugh and
the more of these stories you read the
funnier it all seems to
get the question of why a never-ending
Ensemble of Terrors is so amusing can be
best answered by the genre bending
horror comedy film The Cabin in the
Woods probably the closest thing to a
big budget SCP movie the story involves
five friends vacationing at a remote
cabin unprepared for the Terrors that
await them what it first feels like
every horror movie ever quickly goes off
the rails as we learn the whole thing is
being orchestrated by a secret
organization that keeps every
conceivable type of monster contained in
an underground facility monsters they
unleash onto unsuspecting youths to
appease the old gods this overabundance
of Horrors is the key to the film's
humor a single Monster stalking a group
of Innocents is horrifying but a
thousand Monsters of contrasting Origins
and genres starts to become well comical
and it's this principle that makes the
SCP Series so entertaining yet beyond
the absurdity of both cabin in the woods
and SCP is a STK commentary on
desensitization in the film the
technicians in charge of the facility
are completely numb to the reality of
what they're doing taking B Nets on
which monsters will Slaughter the cabin
goers in many SCP stories Foundation
employees behave the same way having
become apathetic to human suffering
after a lifetime of containing anomalies
and both narratives implicate the viewer
as well in Cabin in the Woods the old
gods are a clear standin for the
audience unfeeling Spectators who demand
sacrifice likewise with SCP the more
entries you read the more you inhabit
the perspective of a foundation employee
clocking in to their job increasingly
unafraid of the nightmares
within the ability of SCP to immerse you
to make you feel like you're part of the
universe has made its strangle hold on
the internet inescapable it leaves you
with a desire to go deeper to experience
the narratives firsthand and I'd wager
that's why games based on the franchise
are so insanely prevalent SCP
containment breach is quite possibly the
most well-known thing ever to crawl out
of the franchise the indie game has an
easy to underand haunted house format
where the deadliest anomalies escape and
hunt you through a dimly lit facility
and shortly after its release
Containment Breach exploded on YouTube
with view counts on playthroughs so high
I'd wager it's how many were introduced
to SCP in the first place but like the
wiki itself SCP games have come a long
long way since Containment Breach with
the most impressive from a standpoint of
sheer creativity probably being secret
files released in 2022 the title puts
you in the shoes of a newcomer to the
foundation who learns about past scps
while working in the archives the story
is divided into chapters each with a
gameplay and art style so distinct they
might as well be different games for
example one chapter is dedicated to the
famous SCP 70 1 or the hanged King's
tragedy a 17th century play that causes
anyone who performs it to lose their
mind appropriately the chapter itself is
chaotic and psychedelic with the player
never certain what's real and what's a
product of the anomaly affecting their
mind from an artistic perspective it's
one of the more immersive ways to
experience a reality bending SCP and can
at times be genuinely spooky on the
opposite end of the tonal spectrum is
the chapter on SCP
1762 a cardboard box that acts as a
portal to a Narnia esque magical land
that paper dragons come out of the
original entry is famous for its
uniquely non horror approach and to
reflect this the art style of this
chapter is bright and painterly and the
game playay is equally Charming instead
of running for your life you use
stickers to bandage the wings of Paper
Dragons and practice your penny flute
for the big recital the whole chapter I
kept waiting for things to get dark and
while like the original entry there is
some truly tear-jerking stuff as the
magical land starts to fade away for the
most part the chapter retains its
storybook presentation throughout taken
as a whole secret files is the ultimate
proof of scp's Versatility that it can
be used to tell stories in any
genre the infinite variability of SCP
means that no single game could ever
embody the series in its totality which
hasn't stopped fans from trying SCP
fragmented Minds is an upcoming
crowdsourced game that seems massively
ambitious taking a more combat oriented
approach in contrast to the more passive
secret files fragmented mind seems to
have a lot of passion behind it but more
than that it seems symptomatic of a
larger dream there's a phantom of a big
budget AAA SCP game that haunts the ever
growing fan base the feverish hope that
one day a Mainline Studio might take a
swing at the franchise it doesn't seem
impossible in fact it might have already
happened the majority of the game
control revolves around the secretive
Federal Bureau of control an off thee
books government agency created to seek
out contain and categorize Supernatural
items called objects of power and if
that sounds familiar it should because
control and SCP are explicitly
irrevocably intertwined the makers of
the game control have stated that the
game's story and atmosphere are heavily
influenced by the SCP series think about
that for a second a major award-winning
company made what is on some level a fan
game of an indie internet horror
Anthology that's pretty unheard of but
the connections between the franchises
goes deeper control takes place within
an altered building called the oldest
house an everchanging structure where
the bureau has set up headquarters
nothing about the oldest house makes
scientific sense its interior is
infinitely larger than its exterior
certain rooms are thresholds to other
dimensions and the building itself can
only be seen by someone explicitly
looking for it and yet despite this
every description of the oldest house
and the altered objects house within are
written in the same dry confident tone
deeply reminiscent of the language used
in SCP entries the same confidence
extends to in-game recordings you can
find where researchers will discuss mind
shattering phenomena like it's all
business as usual there's even an insane
puppet show called threshold kids The
Bureau created to reassure children that
there's definitely nothing to worry
about sure the building seems malignant
and is full of floating zombies but
everything is under control it only
takes a few minutes of actual gameplay
to make it clear that no one in the game
control is actually well in control the
notion that layers of bureaucracy and
paperwork can actually contain the
unfathomable Horrors longterm is Just an
Illusion and the same is true at the SCP
Foundation despite the foundation's best
efforts the deeper into the lore you get
the more patterns of administrative
dysfunction emerge as in control the
foundation is ultimately an underere
equipped group fighting a losing battle
against forces they can't truly
understand
many of the most complex recent stories
set in the SCP Universe emphasize this
hopelessness the sense that the
foundation isn't as in control as they'd
like to believe the recent 20-minute
film 096 by clabel explores the tragedy
and horror that occurs when the cracks
in the foundation system start to show
the film's title comes from scp096 a
monster that hunts down anyone who looks
at its face whether it be directly via
video recording or even a photograph yet
the other Monster haunting the film is
the foundation itself a faceless
bureaucracy Laden with internal
corruption that can be just as dangerous
as the anomalies it contains the fact
that this franchise went from a bunch of
people sharing spooky ideas on a message
board to something this thematically
dense is pretty astonishing and 096
isn't the only SCP adaptation of its
level of quality on YouTube SCP overlord
by Steven Hancock and Evan murer is an
even lengthier short film that captures
a similar atmosphere of powerlessness a
tightly wound Thriller it follows a
group of foundation military operatives
who are slowly picked off by an
incomprehensible threat made all the
more unsettling by the fact that the
film never tells you which SCP is taking
them out these filmmakers have made
other shorts set in this universe that
also don't fully explain which anomaly
the protagonists are dealing with which
helps put the viewer in their shoes and
makes everything tenser there's a clear
hunger for cinematic takes on this
franchise SCP Overlord for example has
almost 18 million views as was the case
with the games I'm sure a lot of fans
discovered SCP through these videos and
some of these new fans will inevitably
create their own scps which will in turn
produce more fan content which will
reach new people continuing an infinite
self-perpetuating
cycle the idea of a website dedicated to
uncanny Terrors that slowly takes over
the Internet is exactly the sort of
thing one might expect to find on the
SCP Wiki but in the ultimate twist that
description applies to the wiki itself
the SCP series and its popularity is the
kind of anomalous phenomena the
foundation would want to contain but it
can't be contained because there's so
much more than I've covered so far there
are entire channels dedicated to going
through each entry in incredible detail
there are graphic novels short stories
other organizations alternate universes
the fandom seems to be ever expanding
completely out of anyone's
control and perhaps that's as it should
be while massive and unwieldy there is
such a range of styles and genres across
this franchise that I truly believe it
is something for everyone in the end the
most important thing the SCP Foundation
offers is a canvas upon which ordinary
passionate creators can leave their Mark
I think that's the real secret to its
success and why this Abyss unfathomable
though it may be is worth staring
into as always thanks for watching if
you enjoyed this entry please lend your
support by liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
to date on all things curious see you in
the next
video